il était une fois un ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui devant le
sénat le 21 janvier
2021 déclara
aucune classe aucune école ne sera
jamais fermé sans l'accord du maire
face aux trop nombreuses charrette de
fermetures de classes que nous
constatons tous dans nos communes nous
nous disons que le ministre de
l'éducation nationale a bien changé
la situation elle n'a pas changé
nous avons dans ces écoles les élèves de
la génération autotests qui vont
terminer leur troisième année scolaire
dans une situation de grande souffrance
psychologique
voire pour certains en plein décrochage
monsieur le premier ministre puisque le
ministre n'est pas là quelle est la
stratégie du gouvernement en matière de
carte scolaire notamment en milieu rural
[Musique]
merci le seul président les élus ruraux
ont le sentiment que l'état ferait tout
pour que la france des campagnes haye de
mal en pis
carburant hors de prix construction et
paix lui interdit communes sont
trésorerie territoire sans téléphonie
médecin parti est maintenant carte
scolaire centrage et tentera de
stratégie c'est une une faute et une
erreur c'est une faute parce que le
ministre de l'éducation nationale ne
tient pas son engagement d'écouter les
élus c'est une erreur parce que la
france des campagnes la france rurale
est en train de se reconstruire grâce à
ses élus
un tenant d'une main la fibre en tenant
de l'autre pour inventer des services en
essayant de sauver des commerces la
modernité c'est la ruralité l'espoir
c'est l'espace alors il est encore temps
de sauver et de revenir sur cette
décision d' en donnant des instructions
pour faire cesser la casse des classes
est sacralisé la ruralité je vous
remercie
merci
[Musique]